- [Voiceover] So in the
last video, I introduced
transformations and how you
can think about functions
as moving points in one
space to points in another,
and here I want to show an
example of what that looks like
when the input space is two-dimensional.
So this over here is the input space.
It's just a copy of the XY plane,
and the output space is also
two-dimensional, so the output
space, in this case, also
a two-dimensional plane.
And what I'm gonna do,
I'm just gonna first play
an example of one of these transformations
and then go through the details
of the underyling function
and how you can understand the
transformation as a result.
So here's what it looks like.
Here's what we're gonna be going towards.
Very complicated, a lot of points moving.
Lots of different things happening here,
and what's common with this sort of thing,
when you're thinking about moving from
two dimensions to two dimensions,
given that it's really the
same space, the XY plane,
you often just think about
the input and output space
all at once, and instead just watch
a copy of that plane move onto itself.
And by the way, when I
say watch, I don't mean
that you'll always have
an animation like this
just sort of sitting in front of you.
When I think about transformations,
it's usually a very
vague thought in the back
of my mind somewhere,
but it helps to understand what's
really going on with the function.
I'll talk about that more at the end,
but first let's just go
into what this function is.
So, the one that I told the
computer to animate here
is f of x,y is the input, is equal to
x squared plus y squared,
as the x component of the output,
and x squared minus y squared
is the y component of the output.
So just to help start understanding this,
let's take a relatively
simple point like the origin.
So here, the origin, which is zero, zero,
and let's think about
what happens to that.
f of zero, zero.
Well, x and y are both
zero, so that top is zero.
And same with the bottom,
that bottom also equals zero.
Which means, it's taking
the 0.00 to itself,
and if you watch the
transformation, what this means
is that the 0.0 stays fixed,
it's like you can hold
your thumb down on it, and
nothing really happens to it.
And in fact, we call this a
fixed point of the function
as a whole, and that kind of terminology
doesn't really make sense unless
you're thinking of the
function as a transformation.
So let's look at another example here.
Let's take a point like one, one.
f of one, one.
So in the input space, let's just kind of
start this thing over so we're
only looking at the input.
In the input space, one,
one, is sitting right here,
and we're wondering
where that's gonna move.
So when we plug it in,
x squared plus y squared
is gonna be one squared plus one squared,
and on the bottom, x
squared minus y squared,
one squared minus y squared.
Woop, (laughs) minus one squared.
I'm plugging things in here.
So that's two, zero.
Two, zero.
Which means we expect this point to move
over to two, zero in some way.
So if we watch the
transformation, we expect
to watch that point move over to here,
and again, it can be hard to follow
because there's a lot of moving parts,
but if you're careful as you watch it,
the point will actually land right there.
And you can, in principle,
do this for any given point
and understand how it
moves from one to another,
but you might ask, hey Grant,
what is the point of all of this?
We have other ways of
visualizing functions that are
more precise, and kinda less
confusing, to be honest.
Factor fields are a great
way for functions like this,
graphs were a great way for functions
with one input and one output.
Why think in terms of transformations?
And the main reason is conceptual.
It's not like you'll have an
animation sitting in front
of you, and it's not
like you're gonna by hand
evaluate a bunch of points
and think of how they move.
But there's a lot of different
concepts in math, and with
functions, where when you
understand it in terms of
a transformation, it gives you
a more nuanced understanding.
Things like derivatives, or the
variations of the derivative
that you're gonna learn with
multi-variable calculus,
there's different ways of understanding it
in terms of stretching or squishing space
and things like this, that doesn't really
have a good analog in terms
of graphs or vector fields.
So it adds a new color
to your understanding.
Also, transformations are a super
important part of linear algebra.
There will come a point
when you start learning
the connection between linear algebra
and multi-variable calculus.
And if you have a strong
conception of transformations,
both in the context of linear algebra
and in the context of
multi-variable calculus,
you'll be in a much better
position to understand
the connection between those two fields.